if I had to choose one laptop right now
for normal daily use it would be the
2020 MacBook Air but not this one after
2 weeks of use and a ton of testing I
changed my mind on this machine and I
wish that it ordered a different one and
even though I think this is a good
laptop for a ton of people it could have
been great if Apple would have made one
small change I'll explain in just a bit
this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
I've read a lot of reviews online and it
seems like many people are just glossing
over some of the negatives I don't know
why but I'm gonna be completely honest
and give you both the good in the bad
and then help you make an informed
decision the 2017 MacBook Air has been
one of if not the best-selling macbook
for years now even after Apple announced
the new one that's because even though
it was underpowered and the display was
outdated the price point was low and
that's what many people care about the
most if they want a basic laptop with
Mac OS the 2020 MacBook Air is finally
going to overtake those sales because
it's better in almost every way and
right now you could buy a brand new one
for nine hundred and fifty dollars which
is actually the same price as a deeply
discounted 2019 model which you would be
absolutely crazy to buy since that one
is worse in many ways I own a lot of
laptops but being quarantined for over
two weeks now and working from home I
realized that there were three reasons
why I kept picking up the 2020 MacBook
Air instead of these others the first
reason was size and weight under three
pounds with a 13 inch form factor it is
really nice for daily use the second is
the wedge shape it may seem trivial but
for longer sessions the tapered edge
doesn't dig into my wrists like these
other boxy laptops do including the
regular MacBook Pros the third reason is
the keyboard this new magic keyboard
really is the best keyboard appleís ever
made and probably my favorite keyboard
I've used in any laptop it is a hybrid
of Apple's previous chiclet keys that
have decent travel and feel with good
reliability and the butterfly keys which
replace them that were wider more stable
and offer more feedback but had poor
travel and questionable reliability to
become
we honest this keyboard feels better
than my standalone keyboard for the Mac
fro it's almost identical but has a bit
more feedback which helps for longer
typing sessions the only way to get this
keyboard right now is to get a 16 inch
MacBook Pro or this new ear and you
can't even compare those due to size and
prices the comparison that's valid is to
the base 13 inch MacBook Pro and after
thoroughly testing the new ear
unfortunately the choice is harder than
ever when Apple launched the new air I
was extremely excited they dropped the
base price by $100 and also doubled the
SSD capacity which is very unlike Apple
resulting in a $300 lower price the
design stayed the same as the Deportes
the webcam and the display the speakers
are similar but they're actually
slightly quieter but sounds slightly
better
[Music]
unfortunately the webcam is still subpar
for 2020 but the microphone quality was
improved and sounds good
here is a sample using the 720p webcam
from the 2019 MacBook Air and this is
the webcam and microphone quality with
the 2020 MacBook Air the RAM is much
faster because of the higher frequencies
and being ddr4 but what I was most
excited about was the new processors and
the graphics which were the biggest
weakness of the previous MacBook Airs
but before I explain why I was let down
let me give a shout-out to our sponsor
Squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website now is the
perfect time and Squarespace is
seriously the best way to go you can
build a great looking website with
literally no web making experience like
we did it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio a blog ecommerce or anything
else you just choose a template and
customize blocks of text and images it's
incredibly simple affordable and ours
have been running flawlessly for over
two years now bringing in new clients
thanks to its built-in SEO tools start
your free two week trial with no credit
card required by going a squarespace.com
slash max tech or by using our custom
link down below and when you're ready to
launch save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain the new MacBook
Air is the first Mac to feature Intel's
10 gen processors which are more
efficient while offering better
performance and it's the first MacBook
Air to have a quad core option in my
first videos on the air I was telling
everyone to spend the extra $100 to get
the quad core i5 which we found out had
the same high end g7 graphics as the i7
which is a $250 upgrade the base is now
a dual core i3 with g4 graphics but it
outperforms the previous dual core i5 by
fair vid and is the biggest generation
leap in performance we've ever seen in a
MacBook Air and that's just looking at
the base dual core if we take a look at
the quad core models we find two things
first off the scores are all over the
place and the second is the i5 and i7
are very close to each other that is
mainly because of thermals and since the
graphic ships are exactly the same I
would not recommend spending the extra
for the i7 because the real-world
performance will be very similar but
more on thermals in just a bit the quad
cores on average score about 40% better
the dual core and when comparing to the
best processors in previous MacBook Airs
the new i-5 smokes them now for a lot of
people that are buying a MacBook Air
maximum performance doesn't matter that
much but what does matter is how snappy
it is for normal use and thanks to the
10th gen CPUs the new air is incredible
with single core performance that even
beats out my 12 core mac pro 16 inch
macbook pro and 13 inch MacBook Pro
because of this for normal tasks it's a
joy to use and is incredibly quick with
no lag on the graphics side the base i3
is almost twice as fast as the previous
best and the quad cores are three times
faster since Mac OS apps are using
graphics more than ever having faster
graphics also accelerates many tasks and
apps because of this incredible
performance I expected the new MacBook
Air to be an easy choice over the 2019
13-inch MacBook Pro we have double the
storage a much nicer keyboard graphics
that are three times as fast at least in
raw metal performance we have a CPU that
is close and multi-core score but much
faster in single core we have better
battery life and on top of that we have
a much lower price that would make it a
no-brainer choice right that is what I
thought but I was wrong see when I
started to push the air and heavier
tasks that I would typically do on a pro
it started to fall apart
it is fairly snappy for photo editing
but for heavier brushes or when
exporting the MacBook Pro is still
faster I thought it'd be great for video
editing and final cut but it definitely
performed worse than the 2019 pro taking
almost twice as long to render a
five-minute 4k project and having more
stutters when you're actually editing
along with that it ran much hotter and
louder when doing all of these tasks and
that is because Apple really dropped the
ball with the cooler the previous airs
did get hot but not too loud but now
that we have these much more powerful
processors our i-5 easily hits a hunch
degree Celsius even in some simple tasks
now Apple doesn't mind them being hot
but if it's running at a constant 100
degree Celsius the fans will ramp up
until they are annoyingly loud like when
I was watching a 4k YouTube video and
the same thing can happen if you have
multiple apps running in the background
and when I was downloading and
installing for tonight the CPU was at a
hundred degree Celsius with fans
spinning high for over an hour this did
not happen with the previous 13-inch
MacBook Air and even though Apple does
put fans in these machines they didn't
connect the heatsink to the fan which
really limits is cooling potential I'm
not sure if this is just negligence or
if it's intentional so that maybe the
MacBook Air doesn't compete with the
MacBook Pro but it is just extremely
disappointing for two reasons the first
is that this air could have been a solid
MacBook Pro alternative but instead if
you push it hard like with cinnamon jar
xx the CPU performance difference jumps
to 65% and if you want to play some
games it is actually slightly slower
instead of being about twice as fast the
second is that people who are not trying
to do these tasks will still experience
more fan noise and more heat than
necessary and at times during normal use
when they're old Mac would be silent
this thing will actually have audible
fan noise especially if they buy the
quad-core model now if you're somebody
that already bought one of these and the
fans are annoying you check out my video
on how to lower fan noise and heat after
this video what really frustrates me is
that all of this could have been avoided
if they would have just spent a few more
dollars for a better heatsink and then
this would be one of the best Mac books
ever released I actually did a video
water cooling this thing and my
conclusion was that if Apple put in a
heatsink we would have gotten at least
25% better performance while running
cooler and quieter because of this I am
no longer recommending most people to
spend extra money on a quad-core yes it
is faster Elise in some tasks but it's
going to be running hotter and also
louder than the i3 and then once it
heats up and slows down the performance
difference is gonna be much smaller if
you need that extra performance either
by a 13-inch MacBook Pro at a discount
which you will link to it down in the
video description or wait for the 2020
13 inch MacBook Pro but the hard part is
we don't really know when that will be
and then of course it is gonna cost more
money as well with all that said I still
really like the 2020 MacBook Air and I
would highly recommend the base model
for most people that don't need a ton of
power the real-world battery life is
about two hours better than the pro in
my day-to-day use it has a sharp above
average display good speakers a normal
function row of keys a with touch ID and
I know some people prefer that it has a
great trackpad a top-of-line keyboard
and it has fast 256 gigs of SSD as the
base model and has performance that does
the job well for the majority of normal
tasks and with all of that said right
now you can buy this for just nine
hundred and fifty dollars which is a
steal for a brand new 2020 MacBook now
if Apple still charged at about 1300
bucks for this I wouldn't be as thrilled
but at this price point for the base
model it is a five out of five for me
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section and if you want the best
price check out the links in the video
description if you need to update your
website or maybe make a new one check
out Squarespace and click that circle
above to subscribe to our channel if you
want to see how this compares to the
13-inch MacBook Pro we have a comparison
right over there and also if you bought
one and it's too loud I have a video on
how to get it to run cooler and quieter
thank you guys for watching this has
been max and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]